[Music]
all right we are back
for another if you have not heard us
duocast
lately it's probably because you're not
on the patreon
eric and i are taking on a new special
topic series
last we did four episodes on cybernetics
and systems theory
we aren't done with it actually that
might come up
here as to why we're not done with it
anyway
the other two guys the other half of the
podcast
they like to take on the political side
of things you know
uh socialism what else did they talk
about eric
well conservatism quite a lot any
anything politics is their game
who's fash who's not good and so on and
so on
i think of them as the um as the more uh
politically engaged side of the duo
and that's our outreach to the
conservatives
they also like to do interviews yeah
whereas i'm not at all opposed to
interviews it just seems like
we haven't even scratched the surface of
the things you
even know as semiotics guy we're
starting to of course
yeah hopefully now we have a chance
yeah so this is our duocasts are for the
segment of the audience who wants to
learn about things hear about things
besides politics
and uh for myself i only want to think
about things besides politics
but it takes all types to make a podcast
of course yeah yeah you'll
hear some conversations that aren't
dictated by political categories
uh which will be nice but i think
politics can be a topic within semiotics
but it's not the focus and that's the
point we're all taking a
breath from politics it's been a bit
rough for the last four
years so there's good reason
anyhow if you are interested in this
topic you want more of it
we are paywalling it except for the
intro so we can introduce it if you want
more
in-depth stuff it's a paywall sorry
we would call this semiotics and
semiology i actually don't know what
we're going to call it
maybe semiotics and semiology because i
know quite a bit about
semiology and only
a lot about one form of semiotics but
eric is a
comparative semiotician so he's gonna be
bringing it
it might turn into an interview because
uh
it's his time to shine if we're talking
about
cyber semiotics and biosemiotics i don't
even know what those things
are but we're gonna learn so in the
series we'll for sure
do a full episode on cs purse
uh those delusions out there deluse
wrote basically the cinema books on
purse plus bergson a dash of
dash of berks and into persian semiotics
so it's true and and guitare as well
right
oh yeah gutturi was um
well they they have a a funny
relationship with semiotics they go for
uh the danish guy uh helmslev
and they have a lot of purse in them too
so they have a kind of a weird
relationship to
uh also cesarean semiology
so that's something that will come up
yeah we always seem to get back to deliz
when we're talking yeah well i i have my
reasons for that i i
find delusion guttari's work to be more
like in my arena and i'm sort of doing
some of it for
my dissertation as well so there's a
couple things going on there but
the losing guttari the way they use
purse is very
interesting to me so i i try to learn a
little bit about it
and they're also a little bit less
explicitly
political defining you know what we
traditionally associate with political
theory
yeah i mean everything goes back to
capitalism
but in a very different way than it does
in the marxist tradition with the losing
gotouri
and they have yeah it does feel like
they just go so far away from politics
sometimes though
uh we might also cover julia christeva i
have to
remember she does something about
anagrammatic
anagramatic semiotics it's been a while
since i've read it but that might be our
our fifth episode or so yeah yeah she'd
be good to do because
she's more in the in the sociean
semiological tradition but she would be
good to do
early on so why is it that when everyone
gets out of grad school
they trounce around and use the word
signifier about every word why can't
they just say word
yeah well when you when you use the word
signifier you're
making its distinction between like the
sign you use to convey your meaning and
the meaning itself
that that's what the sign distinguishes
when you're using it in that sort of
two-part structure way there's a
signifier and a signified
and it's because often these the
signifieds are sus
so if you say something like free market
you know what both of those words mean
independently and you combine them
then how could it not be a good thing
yeah but you're suss about the signifier
same with something like uh
american dream you're drawing attention
to the fact that
the what the word purports to mean
and what it actually means are two very
different things yeah
yeah like this this distinction between
like
the signifier and the signified opens
the door for all kinds of
interesting insights because now you can
talk about
the ways you go about making your
meaning
separately from the meaning itself and
the system of like
concepts and ideas that what you're
saying links into
so you can treat these separately and
that's part of the interesting
part about this distinction and of
course the signifier
is usually seen as like the material
component it's the
sound you make or it's the letters you
write down and so that
can be studied on its own and like in a
really extreme way like if you're
studying ancient writing or something
you have no idea what any of it means
you just have the writing left over
those are just like
signifiers with no signifieds in our
universe
right right and when when people talk
about there's a gap
obviously there's a gap between the
signifier and the signified
that's interestingly where ideology can
slip
in there and then you can have something
that's referred to
that is either opposite from the word or
very different from the word
and then we're kind of slipping into
post-structuralism as opposed to
structuralism but in terms of a french
context
when you're speaking about structuralism
you're talking about one guy mainly
who's also the
founder of semiotics despite the fact
that i think he only ever published one
book
well uh anyway i won't leave you hanging
we're talking about ferdinand
the social i'm here don't worry no he
didn't he didn't publish that book he
he uh he gave no he published one of the
lectures that his students recorded and
put in the book and it's oh yeah oh
you're talking about his other book yeah
oh
i i don't know anything about that one
no i've
i've never read it either but uh yeah
what's it called
i don't think anyone's actually read it
that's the thing yeah i'm pr
i think i think maybe maya sue might
have read it
it's like okay it's called uh
memoir on the primitive system of vowels
in
indo-european languages yeah he well he
was a linguist
yeah and that's i guess that's his only
authored book
i mean there's still stuff coming out
like they found another manuscript of
his
in like the 90s oh wow in his like
summer home in switzerland or something
like that they found a new
unpublished work by him so there's still
stuff coming out
with him as well and like his tradition
is really contested
especially because the book you're
talking about isn't the book that
semiology comes from it's the other one
the other book that he didn't publish
because he didn't write it
he gave them his lectures and the
lectures were compiled as
student notes after the fact and then
they published it as a book called
course in general linguistics
and this is where we get the linguistic
turn in french theory that
inspires uh i could just name any of
them pretty much but levy strauss
roland bart uh derrida altuzer
lacan christeva and on and on ago
uh but they were the ones that were
responding to this and that's why
about half of the names i mentioned
right down the middle
are considered post-structuralist as
opposed to structural yeah
his work was the basis for the
linguistic turn it didn't quite come
during his lifetime
but but later on in in france and
in other areas of europe as well with
the the focus on linguistics
and the turn to a sort of
language-oriented
philosophical thinking as well that
started to dominate
so that's the french side and if you pay
attention to
any of my content it's all about the
french side
but there's another side of semiotics
well at least one other there's
there's several none of which i know
anything about
so eric can you give us like an intro to
at the
anglo slash other world of semiotics
besides that before we dive into this uh
sorcerer business
yeah alt-sem alternate semiotics
yeah yeah well uh usually socer
is taught as the founder of of semiotics
usually a lot because he's um it's
convenient
and his system is a little bit easier to
teach and apply
and all the famous people wrote on his
version yeah and he's like
yeah he's well ensconced in scholarship
at this point running back many many
years
uh but the other the other tradition
actually comes from
a guy who was actually got to it a bit
earlier
so this this is like a little bit like a
calculus story two
two people independently discover the
same
sort of field within a few
years of each other without knowing each
other so this is charles sanders purse
from
america from from new england and he
is actually the original founder of
semiotics in its modern
form of course um yeah and
he wrote a load of works i think the
first thing that got famous by him was
probably a series of letters he
exchanged with a
lady in england named lady welby and
those got passed around and people
started to read his stuff
and it was very different from saucers
and it really it spawned its own
tradition with different people involved
and it's popped up today in in different
forms as well
and it really has not much to do with so
sir and that tradition but it's
there are people who noticed him of
course throughout all of it
but really so sir is dominated in french
theory at least
and by the way we should acknowledge we
er eric has a bit of bias because
cs purse or charles sanders purse is his
guy
yeah and i have never read it in the
original
i've read a lot of these references to
him and never read his original
layout of here's my structure so i'm
excited
for this series because i'm going to
learn this stuff well
i should i should preface that then
because person never laid out his own
stuff there's no
like place you can just go into purse's
work be like where does he
like just lay all this out there's
nowhere there's nothing it's fragments
it's bits and pieces from different
works at different points in his life
like this has been a big part of why the
persian tradition also
kind of laid a bit more dormant than
socers did
is because of this difficulty with
defining it well that would have been a
good career decision on his
part to do that but um it's yeah it's
widely acknowledged including by de los
got into angeles you can basically see
his graphs
in the de la's cinema books if you
uh open them up so yeah i know i know
what those graphs say but i don't know
what
purse said so we're gonna get into that
in another episode
um unless you do you want to introduce
it and can you do like a five minute
appeal to why purse is superior to
society and
sembiotics oh my god like
partly because partly because i'm
interested in it so i just prefer it
but yeah we got the bias out of the way
so now just that's a big part of it i
don't know the other the other part of
it is
is i've i've always been
kind of more attracted to a a realism
i guess you could say like my particular
trajectory
i went through i don't know you could
say
like walter benjamin and bruno latour
and like more materialist focused
philosophy but
yeah the reason i prefer purse is
because he has that
that triple structure of the sign he's
got a role for the object and thinking
and it's relatively independent of our
minds but it's not
completely and in a way that just
broadens the application of semiotics in
a way that i
that i like because i'm also into
environmental theory
and if you talk about it from within a
syrian tradition there are certain
limitations
i feel like you run up against and that
the persian
tradition helps you get around a little
bit so that's the more
that's the more boring explanation
yeah that might that might just become
an interview we'll probably do that
uh next week or so anyway
for now the most influential
if not the best system is that
of ferdinand de socier uh
swiss i think he was in geneva
is that right do you know yeah i think
it's geneva i'm quite sure i'm at a i'm
at a 90
certain time i think there's a
university there and i think that's
where he taught
but yeah he never he never published his
theories he died
uh relatively early i don't know if it
was an accident or what but he never got
around
to writing the book on semiotics
but his students took notes took good
notes in his lectures
shout out to all those students out
there and they made a book out of it
and that book is now the definitive uh
guide to semiology yeah 1916 i think it
was of course in general linguistics
so sir died a year or two earlier all
right so we're going to be using these
two terms
to an extent but just so everybody knows
what's the difference
uh eric can you explain to me the
difference between
semiotics and semiology well
i think the way we use the term when we
talk about semiotics and the
sort of signs and signifiers and all
that sort of stuff
we tend to refer to
the sosurian tradition and so sir used
the word semiology to describe
the sort of science like he didn't he
wasn't even doing semiology himself he
was doing linguistics
but he was focusing on the linguistic
sign
like what does it mean how does it mean
and he
he kind of envisioned a science that he
didn't really know
what kind of shape it would take uh
that's one of the last quotes i think
from
of course in general linguistics but he
kind of projected the science and he
named it semiology
the science of science and he imagined
it would be a part
of social psychology and that
linguistics would then become a part of
semiology
and so that's the way he used it and
people sort of blew past his warning
about
like we don't know what this is going to
look like yet and
people started just developing their
systems
and semiotics usually refers to yeah
like
when you're studying purse you get to
learn that yeah like semiotics refers
we should use it to refer to the persian
tradition so sort of
wider if if so sir's semiology is all
about human language and linguistics
then semiotics should encompass any kind
of
sign exchanges whatsoever not just
limited to
human language systems but also
you know quote unquote primitive
language too like we might see in
animals or in i don't know plants in the
natural world
basically because human culture the
argument here is always brought up the
human culture is embedded in nature
it's an extension of nature in many ways
it's not something that
transcends nature it's not something
that
i mean you could call it a unique
appearance within nature it's
qualitatively different than anything
else that's been around but
the the idea is to broaden the focus and
start talking about semiotics as
something that
maybe exceeds semiology and social
psychology in a way
and this is where we start brushing up
against a word that i've already said
bio semiotics do you have an example of
where
signs would be used in nature
completely apart from you know human
human interpretation
semiotics and the exchange of signs the
action of signs
is sort of co-extensive with life
itself like life is a sign producing
communicating and reading phenomenon so
could you refer to
like the way that birds signal each
other
for example with color or whatever could
that be a part of biosemiotics
yeah like the idea is that you find
signs in the most basic forms of life
so well birds aren't really the most
basic forms of life
but you can see that animals are sign
exchanging creatures
and they don't they don't just run on
instincts like a machine
they also have a sort of freedom to
interpret their environment
and a freedom to also create signs and
like send out signs that serve their own
purposes
for i i always give the example of of
the bird that fakes a broken wing
there's a type of bird i mean i forget
what it is now there's a type of bird
that'll fake a broken wing
to lure a predator away from its nest
maybe it's like trying to climb the tree
or something like that
and then when the predator turns towards
it and moves towards it it
gets up flies away and the idea is just
that
the ability to lie and assume that
there's some other receptive being
that's going to interpret your lie in
the way you want them to
there's already a pretty like
substantial cognitive
structure that must be in place and
in a way biosemiotics looks at well how
is this an example
of a sort of more print like i said a
primitive sort of use of signs
and sign exchange and that's that's so
so obviously when you do that you're not
just going to think of it
an analogy to human language
that would be kind of that would be kind
of like you know anthropomorphic right
and that's something we
kind of want to avoid sometimes but so
you got to think of it as qualitatively
different than
what humans are used to earlier phase in
evolution may be for human beings so
it's part of the structure there too
but you know it's also different for
other species right we have sort of
species specific
modes of communication that utilize
science
yeah right so as soon as linguistics
comes into play and semiotics
from the very beginning has been very
biased towards human interpretation
thinking that it's something abstract
thinking that over we are referring to
ideas we're not just referring to
you know pointing at things we have a
complex language and so
on and uh yeah so there's been i
wouldn't call uh
biosemiotics a discipline it's at least
a sub discipline but it's getting some
interest
in a way that we're pushing sign
recognition and sign use
away from just humans specifically
but humans more than any other species
or social group
use signs all the time we could refer to
street signs
they don't just they're not just there
for uh decoration every sign
obviously means something and in meaning
something it's controlling
a situation in a certain way so that we
can have
a sort of shared world and that brings
us
to so sir oh that could bring us to so
many things
well i think i think we've got to cover
so sorry so that people know what
signifier means yeah because everyone's
on about oh that's just a signifier
that's a floating signifier that's a
non-referential signifier yeah okay
i i i hear it more often from people who
i suspect don't know what it means
yeah well we'll talk about that maybe
later floating signal
but yeah what is a signifier yeah we can
start with just
what is a signifier and i think from
here on out we'll be
breaking down the sosurian tradition
because if you've read any french people
they're referring to him except for
dallas
but you still got to read saucer to know
what delusion ghateri were reacting to
and what basically all their
contemporaries were reacting to as well
it's a very helpful thing to know
all right so i don't know what your uh
well your first
step into this would be eric but for me
the one thing that defines
semiotics from previous linguistics or
linguistics before or hermeneutics
we could also talk about how how you
psychologically interpret things
but for semiotics the key difference is
that
the word that you use to refer to the
thing
and the thing refers to sort of a mental
idea
is completely arbitrary there's no
definite relation between
a word and the thing and if you've heard
people use the word tree
that's because tree is the example on
like the third page of sorcerer's
text there's nothing in a tree
that gives you the word tree and this
seems very
natural for us to assume because this is
the way all of us think of language
but uh for whatever reason at the time
of
at the time of writing no one had said
that language is just completely
accidental and it goes a little bit
further than that that i want to
pick up on it's that the world does not
have a predefined shape it's not
a world of you know the
story of of adam when god brings all the
animals to him and he's like we need you
to name everything oh yeah yeah
the sosurian idea is that you don't even
know what to name
until it already is named and once it is
named
that's going to be culturally relative
it's going to depend on your context
what you think is important to
have a name so it's not like everything
has a name in every language some
languages
privilege specific sorts of names like
the example this this is where i go to
in my head i don't even know if this is
true or not
but like the inuit have 20 words for
snow
i don't know if that's true but i can
believe it's true
because they're dealing with a lot of
more kinds of snow
than someone like closer to the equator
would be
there's there would be building snow
there would be like
wet snow that you have to watch out for
so you would need a bunch of different
words for the same thing in english
which is just snow if you were trying to
have a whole bunch of use values out of
different kinds of snow
and that's kind of where so sir is
coming from
your use value for things in the world
determines
the things that you need names for and
that's culturally different
that depends on not the structure of
language itself but the structure of
your particular
language and then out of where your
culture exists
then you're going to need a lot of
different words for a lot of different
phenomena
yeah i think that's exactly right um
yeah the one of the major points is
yeah that so if you're looking at the
sosurian structure of the sign
right it's a bipartite sign it has two
parts
as the signifier and the signified and
that's where the arbitrary relation lies
between those two so water is called
water not because
there's something watery about the word
water it's just
an arbitrary name you could call it oh
for example like the french do but
the yeah the the the adam example is
interesting uh
like walter benjamin actually writes a
beautiful essay about this called
on language of such in the language of
man and he writes about the
the adamic naming system that like
story of adam where he names all the
creatures
and the idea is that adam finds the name
that fits the thing
right adam's adam's names that he gives
to things because adam and eve share the
language of god
and the language of god is you know it
it cuts to the core of things it's
creative you know in the beginning was
the word
so in being able to share this language
in
in naming things they match the name to
the essence of the thing
and benjamin's point was that we're no
longer you know our language
after all these tragedies babel and
things like that
we're no longer connected to the essence
of the thing so our names become
sort of arbitrary and then there's a
whole other way benjamin takes it but
the
the idea is that yeah the names we give
to things don't really get at the
essence of the thing they're arbitrary
and even if you say well what about
onomatopoeia
for example what about words for things
that sound like the thing that
surely that captures the essence of the
thing but
like boom or yeah
yeah or bark yeah exactly but even even
that case you just
there's the cultural differences kind of
overwrite that because you
you know you go to france and they have
different sounds for dogs and cats they
make than english speakers do
people and people in spanish-speaking
countries again have different sounds
than french or english people do for
animals so it's not it's still
culturally relative in that sense
so even in that case it's still a kind
of
arbitrary connection to something that
you name it cat's meow
meow is the arbitrary word for the sound
that cats make
it's still a thing i do gotta say moo is
pretty close
i've been around a lot of cows well i
can't interpret too many other sounds
out of moo than moo
i mean i get pretty weird like moo the
sound we make with our lips i don't
think cows have
lips and then the way we write it into
the word moo
is just another remove away from the
thing cows do
yeah i don't mean to distract from your
point because that is a
sorcerer's actual point no no i wish we
had
we could have prepared examples if we
had knew this but like
even in english you can say for a dog
bark obviously dogs don't have lips
so they can't make the sound bark but
they can make the sound arf arf
or wolf woof and that's kind of putting
human language onto
an automata piac example that doesn't
actually
hold hold the word there but yeah every
kid
says oh the dog says woof woof not
really yeah
kids are really bad at it too and so is
i mean you just go watch like the old
batman series with adam west and they
come up with all kinds of crazy things
for sounds biff and buff and boop
yeah the point is even onomatopoeia is
arbitrary and that just really
reinforces the point that the
sign is arbitrary i mean really there's
three
there's three principles to keep in mind
with the society and sign one it's
arbitrary
two it's conventional it and three
language is a communal system so signs
are never private things they're
held in they're held by the public and
that's the condition that we can
understand each other is that our
language is common
and therefore we cannot just change it
at our will
that's a huge important point you know
you point oh what about shakespeare yeah
well okay but
you can't just change the language at
will
it it doesn't work that way you know new
new symbols and words can develop and
gain meaning and change over time
but the point is you know if that was if
that process were very sudden then we
would be in a lot of trouble
so there is continuity those three
principles i think are good to keep in
mind those
really describe sorcerer's conception of
the sign in general
well we can add some terms like yolo
probably added to the dictionary by now
but yeah yeah the thing is
when you say arbitrary it doesn't mean
that you can just make up any word
because if you make up a word no one's
gonna know what you're saying
but it's socially arbitrary in the sense
that they don't have
any actual real connection
to the thing that you're talking about
so that
for your community whatever your
community is like i use the inuit as an
example
they're gonna have concerns about
cold weather and types of weather that
you wouldn't have if you were
closer to the equation yeah that's right
yeah your language communities
is what's important here and it's like
you that's like the the unit of
historical analysis and languages
it's the language community and just
think about the ways people argue about
old indo-european languages and things
like that
like normally it's the the language
community marks the
the borders there i was trying to
consider the way that this cashes out
downstream with uh
like altuzer responds to this in terms
of
or like in a marxist perspective
right um you have bart who takes this
and says
not only are just words themselves
signs but we can look at advertising as
signs in his book
uh mythologies where he just breaks down
commercials and he says like
this soap stands in for the cleansing
blood of christ because
and this is still true to this day if
you watch a commercial on
with soap or detergent or any cleaning
agent
you have these visualizations of the
soap going in
and removing like the evil the the dust
the dirt the
bacteria if it's like febreze or
whatever
you you get these visualizations of this
cleansing
soap stuff that's uh you know
it has the effect of the blood of christ
at that point
downstream it becomes like yeah
commodities themselves
are signs yeah and we can carry this to
um signs of exclusivity signs of
luxury the the luxury goods like
uh i'm so bad at this but
like prada or louis vuitton or whatever
when you when you see someone wearing
that then you're going to know this is a
sign of wealth so
everything is not just what you see
but once it's branded in a symbolic
shared experience then it takes on all
these other meanings
including for example wealth luxury
or a cleansing liquid
yeah there's a few there's a few things
to get through to get to that point now
i know you're going one of them is
is first how do we get to structuralism
from so sir
and all this nonsense about science and
the other thing is
what happens with post-structuralism
and the deconstructive moment what
happens with
so sir and the sign then
so so the the one question is is
has to do with the structure of the sign
itself and the arbitrary connection to
it with
with derrida right he takes that to its
logical conclusion basically and says
why even talk about
signifieds at all so let's go back
the the signifier is linked to a
signified with through an arbitrary
connection
and the signifier is not just a thing
around you right a signifier is not
anything on your desk
it's not anything that well is sort of
something you're thinking of but it's
not exactly right so what
the signifier is called in the interest
of getting this down so we can talk
about
things like floating signifiers later
signifiers
are what are called
uh sound images right that's what
they're called
sound image and it's a pattern basically
right and so both components of the sign
are psychological
so this first one the sound pattern is a
psychological connection you have in
your mind
to one sort of stream of consciousness
you could say
and then there's a parallel stream and
that's the signified
so the signifier what it does is it it
constructs
signs through you know the use of
of symbols and words and sounds and all
sorts of things
and it's paired to a meaning and that
meaning is is also
a concept right so it's an idea
so both the signifier and the signified
are both mental constructs that are just
arbitrarily connected to one another and
distinguished
in so far as one is the thing you do
to indicate the idea and the other thing
is the idea
indicated right so the signified
is usually thought of as the meaning
or the concept that the sign the
signifier part of the sign
is referring to and so
and we can before you go on we can just
play with our
listeners for a second and just say
don't think of a pink elephant
so what happened is i said
despite all this technological
intervention between us
i'm talking into a mic this mic is being
converted and uh
recording onto my computer as a digital
file
nevertheless it goes through whatever
process so that
the speakers or earphones that you're
listening to compress the air
the second you hear the word pink
elephant
now you know exactly what i'm talking
about despite the fact that you're
trying not to think about it because
that was the uh
the imperative there right so eric where
where in there do those two things pink
elephant
where is the difference between the
signifier and the signified
because these things don't exist right
so this is kind of important to the
point
yeah so presumably if i'm speaking to
you about a pink elephant i use that
word
i use those words pink elephant
supposedly we
we share a language community in which
that meaning is set
right that that it's conventional
in the context of our exchange and so
when i say
pink elephant you know what i mean
because of that convention because of
the
like that's what is come to understand
is the structure
and so the specific pink like whether or
not there's a pink elephant i want you
to think in abstract terms if you just
think of an elephant and
it's pink or i actually oh my god i saw
a pink elephant the other day on uh
on planet earth whether or not like
there's still
there's got to be a convention a concept
that we both
share that we both in order for us to
understand each other
we need to share that sort of connection
right and this is uh getting to one of
sauser's most famous other quotes which
is
language is a system of differences so
despite the fact
that pink and elephant don't go together
in real life you don't observe a pink
elephant it's very easy to imagine one
because you can imagine a gray elephant
but you can create the difference in
your mind between a gray
and a pink elephant and now not
everyone's
image in their head is gonna look the
same
they're the pink elephant it's probably
gonna be based on a collection of images
they have in their head of where they
learned okay this is not
a rhino it's an elephant this is not a
mammoth
this is an elephant and you learn that
before you even
like basically have a memory when you
learn to say this is not that this is
something else
and that's where language is a system of
differences comes in
because then you can connect these
differences together
despite the fact you've never seen them
together
right so the system of differences gets
them to this sense of arbitrariness
in language that you can combine things
that
you've never seen but you can make
differences
because probably what your some sort of
your psychological process is
unconsciously right before you actually
experience it it's gonna be i
i think of a a gray elephant and turn it
pink
because i know what gray means and i
know what
pink means you're right yeah yeah i
[ __ ] up i should have
i should have also had differential on
the list too yeah
okay so the three fundamental things are
are the language there's an arbitrary
connection to the signifier and the
signified
between them there's a conventional
or like languages communal that should
be one thing
and yes the sign is differential which
means that we understand it because of
what it's not
that's very strange but that's a
principle of language
and it yields some pretty good uh
insights i think
but the way to well you kind of you kind
of i want to bring this back down to
earth a little bit you figure this out
when you have kids in your life
god that sounds bad yeah okay all right
i got a nephew
i got a nephew i don't have other kids
in my life
but the kid points at
uh like a fire truck and goes train
and the learning process there is you
say
no not train fire truck
so you correct their problems of
learning differences
they say car you say no that's not a car
that's a truck
and you forget that you've learned all
that stuff but even learning language as
a process is learning
more what not to say than what to
actually
say yeah so if you point to a tree and
say
tree to a person who doesn't know what a
tree is
they could think green they could think
bark
they could think tall
but unless you teach them also the
meaning of
grass bush green
then they're not going to know what
exactly a tree designates but even after
learning the word tree
you're not going to have the same word
idea
in your head as another person when they
learn the word tree yeah maybe when i
say tree
50 of the audience thinks of a deciduous
tree and 50
thinks of a coniferous tree there's no
there's no way to measure that but you
would still be right
but you're learning that based on a
series of differences i don't think
anyone
is thinking bush after having heard the
word tree because you know what a bush
is and you know what a tree is
yeah yeah that's a really fundamental
point
yeah so when you another example
of a sign system is when you you know
the lights system right the
street lights traffic lights so green
yellow red
and the what differential kind of cashes
out to mean is that when you pull up to
a light
and you see you look at the color the
color is red
you're going to understand like the
meaning of red based on what it's not
so you don't you don't you know and
you're not conscious of this you're not
sitting there thinking okay
not green not yellow so i stop
but within a sign system it's about the
distinctions like the sign
you might say the sign obtains its value
within the system of signs
based on the differential relations it
has
with all the other signs around it so
things like things like taxonomy when
you're classifying animals right and
and or just like you said trees
like i know trees because like not shrub
not bush
not grass i know because it's not all of
these other things i know my dog is not
a cat
i know my school is not a hospital
like you have these sorts of clusters of
concepts that come into place
and the differential relationship
between all of them is the source of the
value of the sign
this might not carry over to all of our
audience but i
i've had this example stuck in my head
because you brought the street lights
but
a lot of the street lights here have the
red light the top one
bigger and i've been to places
in the united states where they have
like horizontal
street lights but for someone who's red
green color blind
they're not going to notice the
difference that you notice
if you're not color blind depending on
them
but they're not going to notice that
they're different colors but they will
notice that one's at the top one's at
the bottom
one's at the right one's on the left so
you can't actually tell
which differences someone else is
viewing
but you can tell that they know a
difference because if they didn't know
the difference they would be uh
crashing into things and driving into
the intersection
so this actually is a an analogy for how
languages cross cultures and you can get
an approximation
but then there's always those
translation differences that you can't
actually account for
because you actually don't know which
differences the other person is
recognizing
versus which ones you are and often
cases when it comes to
you know non-theoretical language if
you're talking about trees
uh snow water
then probably most cultures are going to
be relatively similar because these are
phenomena that you would have named
in like the stone age but when it comes
to theoretical language or translating
philosophy texts or translating
a compound german word into english
where you have to put a whole bunch of
dashes in between them
then that stuff starts to get
complicated and then you don't know you
don't even know what meaning
you're missing unless you can figure out
how to read the original
yeah especially if you're trying to
capture the word play going on too then
it becomes impossible
which is why philosophy is impossible to
translate
in many cases poetry too yeah poetry
takes that to its extreme
and really focuses a lot on you say the
level of the signifier
and less so the signified so in english
i mean here's an example that is
pertinent to our discussion here
so sir uses three words that could all
be translated into
language in english
langage la long and
la parole so the first one just refers
to
communication that could mean in english
we'd call it body language
it could mean like these these gestural
supplements or tone tonality that would
change and la long then means
the full language
you could say um
lelong anglais
oh sorry it would be anglaise la long
anglaise
in french would be the english language
but it also means the structure of
language more generally speaking
but that's the structure that's like if
you added up all the words that exist in
a language there you have
the language and all the rules the the
rules that are strict
that you you know have to put the
subject first and then the object second
or whatever
but then you have parole
where this is every single speech act
and this is like even at this very
moment there's an
infinite amount of english speech acts
being carried out um in every corner of
the world
australia uh india
england canada africa
all at the same time there's all these
english speech acts
and then this is where changes and
dialect actually come from
because you have to adapt the language
to be
util in different situations so when
you're talking about a speech
act saying this thing needs to be
communicated
and there's like a slippage or i need to
be more specific
or i need to invent a new word to be
able to
engage this socially and you can never
invent a word by yourself
like we already said but these speech
acts are what cause the evolution
of language so obviously latin
evolves into romanian
italian french spanish
or because of actually environmental
pressures that force
these speech acts to address their
environment
one of the common criticisms against so
sir is that he has now
history to language and that's true in
one sense
that we'll probably get to on a later
episode i don't want to bring that all
up now
but his reason for saying that the the
environment actually forces languages to
change
over time which is how you get something
like a genetic drift
in the same way that you'd get a drift
in species from language to language
yeah yeah the idea of change over time
is interesting because like how does
something new emerge
yeah if you if you just picture long as
like the rules of chess
and then parole as like an actual game
of chess that you're playing
then you can never do anything new in
that situation if you try to move your
pawns sideways you'll probably get
yelled at
by your opponent you can't do it so if
if language is really that
strictly rule-bound then how does it
ever change
and then again that suggests that the
meaningful changes the changes that
we're looking for
are on the level of long and not on the
level of
parole because parole is changing and
shifting all the time but the idea is
like what rules get
specified and get translated into the
rule book
kind of thing right right and that's why
we can't read like
we can't read chaucer anymore because
it's actually the long
english the laws just changed old
english middle english
modern english they're those are shifts
even like the
great the great vowel shift yeah that's
that's that's a change in long
whereas like parole would have been
involved and those things would have
manifested through it but we think like
okay so how does it work what's the
relationship between the two
and for so cert you know you have to
break it down into two other dimensions
which is synchronic and diacronic
you know sync like a synchronic cross
section it's all at once
you take language as it is at one moment
and look at its
structure right like what are the rules
of chess in
1995 in the world tournament and speed
chess what are the rules
and then we get a structure of rules but
then diacronic
you look at you you're sort of more
forced to look at speech
and language over time and so
you know my sentence unfolds in time
when i say it my the first word i utter
is necessarily earlier in time
than the last time but the structure
remains the same throughout all of that
if the structure of my language was
changing while i was speaking it we
would also have another problem
so that's a big focus of this kind of
and then this is where structuralism
comes in because it wants to look at
these sorts of
we're going to get to the idea of deep
structures right
even even deeper than just the language
we use
myth myth and politics
will be some of those things that get
investigated but just in terms of long
and parole right it's every
like it's what you wear in the morning
it's parole right you
the fashion system whatever is in your
closet is part of some fashion system
that has
rules and your parole is is what you
wear in the morning that's that's sort
of
barth's this fashion analysis so you
know
like this hat is red so i have to wear a
shirt that complements it maybe i should
wear something a bit dark and
um now what my shoes have to be or if
you think about like i don't know
if you guys out there have girlfriends
think about the way they dress and how
they mull over the rules too
you do everybody does it and so
the rules are applied in an
utterance to use the language metaphor
and with fashion the utterance is what
you choose to wear in that day
and the idea of the structure
how that comes into play is very
interesting in this whole situation
because
when we want to bring in ideas from
marxism you hint it a little bit out
with value but we want to bring ideas of
marxism into play with this sort of
stuff and we talk about ideology so
ideology we picture it as
as maybe a sort of a second order
system of signifieds right ideology is
the political side and myth
would be the sort of human nature
relationship side these come into play
as
like overcoatings that code over
our use of language and code over the
systems
of meaning or you know signifiers
phonemes and that
that inform our choices in the moments
so when we're looking at
what structuralism is interested in is
because it's not real
interested in what we say but the
relationships between the things that we
say
because those express the sorts of rules
that are structuring the language game
that we're playing and those language
games that we play the rules of those
games are then coded over
by ideology liberalism socialism
conservatism do i want to be an economic
liberalist do i want to be a social
liver it's it it becomes a sort of
overcoating and it
it starts to influence the meanings that
we use from above
in a certain way right so when i you
know
words change their meanings over time
because these overcoatings also
change and the same with myth right
barth goes into this in mythologies in
great detail the ways that
celebrities and politicians will channel
these ancient sort of
mythic structures in our language in
order to you know
sell themselves marketing to sell
products
connect it with mythological signifieds
as they would say deep the deep
structure the signifieds that exist
beyond
our sorts of intentions but shape them
at the same time
so all that comes into play too and i
mean i
know i just said a lot but it's a lot to
get to so
sir laying down his theories versus the
way it was taken up by the french
structuralists and other people
throughout the 30s and 40s it kind of
gets to one of our themes
as a as a duo at least is that the
difference between long and parole
parole is pushing the rules like you
could put poetry
or or word play into
parole but for something to change the
structure
it almost never happens but it does
happen
right so this is a sort of a systems
theory perspective that we can apply
here
that no no one conscious person no
matter how much they try
can actually change la long
in a language you can change parole as
much as you want try to play around with
it
but for something to actually take shape
that's unpredictable
like what's his name that the one
direction guy wears a dress
and uh half of the people freak out that
like oh he's so brave it's so beautiful
that he's doing this and the other half
are like we've lost real men
because men are now wearing dresses in
our society
or whatever so he broke a rule but it's
not like
guys on mass are suddenly wearing
dresses because of that
i mean in in in 200 years a bunch of
things might happen that
that make that a consequence but you
can't
change a rule system of language
overnight
yet we can see that it changes because
in 100 a.d french and spanish were the
same thing and in
2000 ad they're obviously not the same
thing anymore such that
a native speaker of one couldn't
understand the other
but even less so for portuguese in
spanish
so yeah there's there's something like a
genetic drift
but this has nothing to do with
conscious agency
that makes you change it and when cesar
was writing
um or when he was when he was young at
least when he was probably studying
for the first time because of you know
the whole colonial situation
languages were coming back from these
other places
and artifacts or whatever and it was
becoming an object of study where it had
never
been before obviously they knew there
was a difference between
german french and english but then they
noticed uh
like sanskrit artifacts were coming back
and then they were noticing
word connections or associations between
latin greek which you know
doctoral students had to know back then
um
and sanskrit words that sounded the same
like uh i idea would be one of the one
of them
in sanskrit's veda or something like
that so
they were noticing these similarities
and this led them to assume
or guess there must be something beneath
all this that is the origin
like the true origin of all language the
language before babel
so they call it proto-indo-european
um and this is sort of intervention
saying like it's not like
proto-indo-european was the original one
it said everything is arbitrary and then
of course
as we've discussed the the uptake of
that into
the theoretical academy was how do we
apply this to advertising how do we
apply this to
ideology how do we apply this to the
history of philosophy
so yeah we're at we're at a big crucial
moment
that it's hard to i mean for me at least
eric i don't know but for you but for me
it's hard to figure out
why this is so surprising but when it's
hard to figure out why something in the
past is so surprising it's probably
because it's had so much influence on
your thought without you knowing it
that's become conventional in a way
it's become a conventional way that we
just look at the world and we're brought
up in it and we don't think about it
anymore probably like
i don't know the first people who
encountered film felt or the first
people who
thought about the uh that unconscious
drives may dictate a lot of our behavior
just nobody thinks that way those things
became a conventional way of
understanding
and then in a way in order to
get a hold of that convention what
sorcerer introduces into that whole
picture
because what you're describing is more
like the diacronic study of language
right over
time and like philologists
you know like like nietzsche even
nietzsche was a train trained as a
philologist
those guys worked on language over time
and
and so sirs kind of prime contribution
is to also
try to say but we also have to think
synchronically about language like what
are the relationships between all the
terms
how is how is there a structure that
generates
all of this change or all of this
process anyway not maybe not change
because a differential
structure yeah yeah so it's not like a
structure of things
it's a structure of relationships and
that's that
right there becomes a little bit
difficult to understand because then we
have to speak about it in
strange like either categorical terms or
in terms of
formal aspects of language you know you
talk about
grammar you talk about all these
different things but yeah so sir's main
contribution was also the idea of seeing
chronic
and people looked at that that's the
structural element right there the
synchronic
structure of language as it produces
like it doesn't produce our speech
situations but it
it circumscribes the sort of horizon of
possibilities at any one moment right
it's a
and and that's linked to culture right
culture is one of those big
sort of horizons of our possibilities we
get our language and our ideas from our
cultural traditions
and so that's the concept in which we're
brought up but those at the same time
those have a in the caesarean tradition
those have a structure
that can be analyzed as well through a
kind of synchronic analysis
at one point in time and then at a later
point in time you can take another cross
section and compare them
and that's how sort of compared
historical or comparative linguistics
works
comparing different cultures or
comparing change over time
while you're bringing it up we don't we
you and i
don't know anything about linguistics
because linguistics is its whole
other thing so we can gesture towards
what it means but when we're talking
about semiotics it actually has nothing
to do
with linguistics i mean they have
relations
but that's something that we couldn't
actually speak on with any knowledge
yeah in a way as opposed to semiotics
yeah like
the the semiotics story always runs up
against chomsky that's the thing right
chomsky's sort of
transformational grammar is what is what
removed semi semiology
at least from the sort of linguistic
core that of of european scholars i
think i think chomsky's theories come
from the maybe the 1950s and the 1960s
and so semiology got sort of booted out
of
linguistics because chomsky's method was
seen as the more scientific one but
semiology then
went to anthropology
as in claude levy strauss it went to
politics and
it went to philosophy and literary
departments
it went to culture studies departments
it was everywhere but linguistics
because then linguistics took
its own sort of scientific turn with
chomsky
so chomsky really booted it out of
linguistics proper
so even though semiology is like
grounded in linguistics it's lost that
institutional connection in a way
and then it's become a sort of thing of
its own i think that's
uh pretty much covers it as an
introduction yeah well there there are
good illustrations of so sarah we didn't
get to uh
we didn't get to purse but he's he's got
a purse has a
has a triple structure of the sign it's
not two parts it's three parts
so that's that's something to look
forward to anyway
uh which brings in more yeah more
i think you said it earlier it's more
realism is involved in it it's not
like all these things are completely
arbitrary because there's a
connection to the object yeah there's a
whole
yeah the object causes the sign in the
persian tradition so it's not
i mean the word referent
is often thrown around in the sausarian
tradition and
like if you go look at fraga right he
made the famous distinction between
sense and reference so the word referent
is thrown around to
look at what's indicated but it's still
sort of
circumscribed within a linguistic
understanding
and it's not really freed in the way it
is in the persian tradition
of of dependency on i'm looking at it
through a lens that's informed by
language and the persian tradition is
not beholden to that kind of lens
yeah this the sorcerer version of it
really stresses
the accidental or arbitrary nature of it
sounds like that there's a a third
element that sort of grounds it in
actual phenomenal experience that's not
just arbitrary all right so we'll look
forward to that next time
uh if you've never heard it before i
hope you like this uh
introduction if you have i hope it was a
bit of a
a refresher because once you read the
works that
you know most of the time that we talk
about it seems
like they totally focus on the
arbitrariness
of science and the the goal at that
point becomes really to intervene in
this arbitrariness of science
and as we've been talking about the
difficulty
is not being able to intervene yeah from
the structuralist perspective i mean
that was
one of the first things dario says is
maybe maybe there's been an event in the
history of structuralism
and that's that's kind of the key point
is that like
how how can there be an event if
everything is already determined by a
structure
we haven't even discussed the medium yet
hopefully if you're uh
into some of these post-modern figures
that you'll
you'll hear some echoes of what they're
going to talk about want to go back and
look at some of this stuff
or follow our series which will be a
short run of episodes after this one
yeah all those things that are forgotten
in the uh
communiques for now why don't we uh wrap
this one up
this pipe is not a pipe
oops there's no mediation whatsoever all
[Music]
right
you